You can see the latest casualty
of the Donald Trump presidential
train wreck continued today
with fast food executive
Andrew Puzder
withdrawing his nomination
for Secretary of Labor,
leaving him free to go back
to his job being the guy
at Illuminati sex parties
who shouts "Ass to ass!"
-(laughter, applause & cheering)
-Ass to ass.
-Ass to ass! Ass to ass!
-HARDWICK: Yeah.
-That's definitely him.
-(laughter)
-Uh, so, all the Trump...
-WIL WHEATON: I feel like
we need to acknowledge
that footballstud6969
-put that...
-Yeah.
...on the Internet for-for,
-like, for all
of humanity to have. -Yeah...
HARDWICK: You know,
what a bummer that there were...
-DREW CAREY: I wonder where the
copies are. -Yeah, I know.
It was a bummer that there were
already 6,968 football studs
-that he had to put
that lat one. -(laughter)
-Well, it's a big country.
-HARDWICK: It is. So,
this Trump drama never ends.
Every day, it feels like
an episode of Game of Thrones,
where you're like, "How can they
keep cramming all this drama
and treachery into such
a short amount of time?"
-(laughter)
-We just need Elizabeth Warren
to swoop in on a dragon,
or Justin Trudeau
to show his dick like Hodor.
-(laughter, applause & cheering)
-So comedi... Yeah.
HEATHER ANNE CAMPBELL:
It's so...
-It's-it's... wide.
-HARDWICK: Yeah, it is.
-It's really wide.
It's gorgeous.
CAREY:
It's in... it's in Canadian.
-(laughter) -HARDWICK:
Oh, 100 points to Drew for that.
That is one exchange rate
I can get behind.
-(laughter)
-CAREY: Or in front of it.
Maple syrup lube?
You got it.
-(laughter) -Next up...
What do you think...?
What crisis do you think
the Trump administration
will face tomorrow?
Anyone can buzz in.
Wil Wheaton.
Kellyanne Conway
will deny her own existence.
HARDWICK: I think
that's possible. Yeah. Points.
-(laughter, applause)
-Mr. Drew Carey.
They're gonna run out of feet
to shoot themselves in.
-(laughter, applause)
-All right, great. Points.
Heather Anne Campbell.
Trump and Putin will be caught
in bed 1969-ing.